we're keeping an eye on the trial and
the killing of ahmad arbury travis
mcmichael which is one of the three men
accused of killing aubry took the stand
earlier today and admitted that contrary
to earlier claims aubrey did not
threaten him in any way the admission is
a blow to the defense who have been
relying on a self-defense argument the
armory trial is not the only major
ongoing test of america's justice system
this week the trial of kyle rittenhouse
is also underway the teenager is accused
of killing two men and wounding a third
during protests in kenosha wisconsin
last august
so joining us now to discuss these cases
and more is yusuf salaam yusuf is one of
the five black and latino boys who were
wrongly accused and convicted of
assaulting and raping a woman in central
park back in 1989. they became known as
the exonerated five after another man
confessed to the crimes the charges
against them have since been vacated
yusuf thank you so much for joining us
welcome to quick take
i want to start with a trial for the
killing of ahmad arbury
what's surprised you so far or has
anything surprised you
you know what surprised me is that we
seem like we are still back in
[Music]
the the past you know we have not moved
forward in any
sense of the word and i think when i
think about this trial i think about the
emmett till trial you know and i'm
saying it incorrectly but you know a lot
of people make the incorrect assumption
that the victim
is the name of the trial itself you know
i remember when i was watching some of
the footage of that trial
they sent it to the jury and the juror
took their time to do what they were
going to do and when they came back and
came back with a verdict of not guilty
they asked the jurors on camera and the
one of the jurors said well we knew we
were going to come back with a soda with
a not guilty verdict we just wanted to
take a sodapop break so that we could
appear to do our jobs i think about this
country that we live in the united
states of america we are divided and
unequal and there are two justice
systems that are running rampant in
these states and you would think that we
would be more progressive today than we
were yesterday
but
i'm still
you know i'm holding my breath wanting
there to be something new that goes on
something positive more reflective but
unfortunately what's happening in the
streets and then spilling over into the
courthouses
continues to make me lose hope of this
system and i want to continue to have
hope
but
yeah when you lose hope that's not a
good thing one lesson that you've
learned through your own experience
something you've said is that instead of
going through something
you should grow through something um
what is one action that the black
community and the country at large can
take to
to grow through this trial and what
we're seeing right now
i think for for the system itself the
system has to grow to be
a system that works
when i look at the constitution of the
united states as a part of the totality
of the system we read the words we the
people and we can take a pregnant pause
and test the temperature in the room and
we critically understand by asking the
question who are we talking about
we know that black and brown bodies were
not considered full human beings that
has never been ratified and so the scary
part is that we are still living in many
ways archaic laws
you know um things that are happening
are not happening because the system is
broken but it's happening was the
because the system
was actually created and working in the
way that it was imagined in the minds of
its creators we need reform when it
comes to that we need reform on the
whole system itself for there to be true
equality and equity going down
and that's kind of what you've dedicated
your life to because after you were
convicted and served time for a crime
that you did not commit you rebuilt your
life you're an activist you're a
motivational speaker
how do you convince people that it is
worth the effort to invest in and help
reform the criminal system rather than
than simply giving up on it
well i'm thinking about the future i say
that the future is alive and well not
because of what the system shows itself
to be today but the fact that when i go
into high schools junior high schools
universities in fact and i talk to the
young people their eyes are beginning to
get brighter and brighter when they hear
my story realizing that my story is not
an anomaly but it's part of the systemic
issues that we experience in america
what they say to themselves is that i am
going to be the change that we need i am
going to be the police officer that is
there to protect and serve i am going to
be the judge that is going to provide
equity when it comes to adjudicating
these cases the prosecutor the judges
the the lawyers in fact
out all the way down to the forensic
scientists and even more
and i think more importantly too is that
that jury pool that we think about often
the people that are there to judge us
that jury pool needs to be educated
beyond what they are educated with now
in understanding that they're holding
people's lives in the balance
they are the justice that is so called
blind and oftentimes they're not we all
come into
the courthouse of the world or our rooms
with preconceived notions as to what
things should be but we need to be able
to understand what truly is at stake our
humanity
so you're saying that people need to be
invested in the system overall and and
see their own role in it um your story
obviously is very powerful and one way
of pursuing
i guess reform in the criminal justice
system is in some ways become a
filmmaker i think of ava duvernay's when
they see us and
obviously on the central park jogger
case in which you were wrongfully
accused and how that raised awareness
and
uh inspired activism
are streaming services like netflix a
good thing overall for for writing
historical wrongs or at least bringing
voice to historical wrongs
one thousand percent you know when
people get the opportunity to see the
truth be told oftentimes it's one thing
to hear about it it's one thing for the
truth especially in our case the central
park jogger case itself that truth was
swept underneath the rug folks did not
get the opportunity to really truly
understand what was going on they were
being tricked right in front of their
eyes big bold headlines were saying
things like dna evidence in the case the
former president donald trump took out
four-page ads calling for the state to
kill us over 32 almost 32 years ago now
right and so we think about all of that
stuff the the murkiness that it leaves
the residue the negative residue that it
leaves in our minds
and
i think when you have the opportunity to
tell the truth you have a raymond
santana reading his false confession as
an adult and it's reading almost as an
adult is speaking it and then he says
what 14 year old boy talks like that and
it's as if the public gets the
opportunity for the first time
to realize how tricked we have been well
we are only one of the can one of the
worms in the can of worms we are only a
microcosm of the cases of
the microcosm of cases
the microcosm of the macrocosm of cases
just like our case and it has to be
looked in in light of the modern eye you
know these new technologies that we are
experiencing which are brilliant you
know being able to show these stories uh
worldwide
same day worldwide is important yeah and
and spark a global conversation uh one
that kind of can take over the internet
and break the internet for a couple of
days as well i i wanna
i wanna get your take on uh your
reaction to the news that oklahoma's
governor has granted clemency to julius
jones uh commuting his death sentence
for a 1999 murder that jones says he did
not commit what was your first thought
when you heard that
you know my first thought was that i was
overjoyed you know i worked for the
campaign to get troy davis free and
unfortunately they did not listen to us
they executed him and they execute many
of us but here is a case where we knew
beyond a shadow of a doubt that this man
did not do this
and yet he still is in prison and we are
overwhelmingly
happy that he that has a lot that his
life has been spared
but there needs to be more he needs to
be freed and i think when we think about
his case in particular yes we love the
fact that we have some uh wins but then
we also have some losses and those
losses is that he has not been freed
from the confines of a place that he
should not be in the first place
yeah and i i see that connection once
again with streaming services because
there was a film on that as well that
brought a lot of attention to uh the
julius jones
situation
i want to go back to self-defense for a
moment here because this comes up both
in the mcmichael trial and the kyle
rittenhouse trial that's taking place
right now
are you keeping an eye on that trial
because i wonder what you think about
the self-defense argument when the
victims are white in the written house
trial versus black
you know when i think about that
self-defense argument i think about
the
facade that we are looking at
when it comes to us understanding what
really is at stake on the one hand
you're talking about a young man who for
all intents and purposes knew that
something terribly wrong was happening
and he decided to try to
figure out how to figure his way forward
and the way that his actions in regards
to ahmed arbury is is deemed is that he
was then now the aggressor
that is that is atrocious
and i think that as a as a as a people
you know as a people who are judging
this case we need to understand what's
what this is all about you cannot use
these types of arguments where you're
hunting people down for game or for
whatever for for sport for play
and then say once the person is murdered
and executed
oh we we didn't mean for that to happen
similarly when you look at the the uh
written case you know
it is um
unfortunate that this young man thought
that it was okay and and more
importantly
it is of the utmost unfortunate
that his mother thought that it was okay
to drive him
to that area
with a weapon
and for him as a young person to engage
in what he thought
was to assist
at least that's what he's saying that is
one of the most awful experiences
i think we have as as people in america
we think that these things are um
just just acts that don't mean anything
but they're all connected and everybody
is at stake everybody is at fault rather
everyone
i want to turn now to uh something else
that happened recently as one of the
exonerated five you know firsthand what
it feels like to be
accused of a crime that you did not
commit and to serve time for that tell
us how you felt when we learned this
week that the two men convicted of
killing malcolm x back in the 1960s will
be exonerated
i think that this is one of the most
happiest days
to find out
that the people who had been languishing
in prison or who were accused of this
crime and went to prison for it
were not the ones who did it we knew
i knew i mean here i'm i'm not even born
in that time
i knew that there was something terribly
wrong with this i knew that it was
impossible for this to happen in the way
that they explained it and so therefore
what this gives us is the opportunity to
look at the
other side of the story
who really is involved who is the
culprit in the murder of our black
prince our black shining prince for that
you know i get the opportunity to share
my story in one of his daughter's
classes at john jay
you know eliasa shabazz she welcomes me
with open arms to show share my story um
of of healing of of of overcoming this
tragic event but here it is we find out
so many decades later that these
individuals who we knew
whether they had some involvement or not
but the fact that we're finding out that
they had no involvement in this crime
it's a happy day
because the people who supported just
like when i when i thought about the
people who supported me and my brothers
it was a small group of people
but finally the truth came out and the
truth came out and gave the people the
understanding that we were the ones that
needed support from the whole community
that psychosocially we mattered i got
the opportunity
to be able to provide my greatest self
because the system said
we want you to be here and by the system
i'm talking about the people in the
community that psychosocial
aspect of the family and i think here it
is you know some of these individuals if
they're still alive or in their 80s
actually one of them is alive yeah
muhammad aziz he's 83. khalil islam died
back in 2009. um i take it you haven't
spoken with muhammad aziz if you were
given the opportunity
what would you say to him now after
hearing what happened what is going to
happen
you know i would i would definitely say
you know welcome home
you know i would i would i would
probably hug him i would probably just
have a moment of
unnamed and unword energy transferring
between he and i
um knowing that we had gone through
something similar of being you know
railroaded in a system
that
doesn't really care about us you know
they care about our bodies being worked
and continued to work as a part of the
new jim crow system that allows slavery
to to exist by another name
but
just letting him know that we are here
that support system that is necessarily
needed for people to be able to be
productive again
to be able to take their dioxy-rival
nucleic acid packaged in their baton as
they pass it back to the new generations
that are coming
they need to know what to do
and how to do it because we're in a
fight
this is a war
and we are the ones that are losing our
lives we are the ones that are seen as
expendable
and i think that we need to be able to
put a human face to the tragedy that we
are experiencing so that we can move
forward as a human family without
the division of color or class
you would show him that you are there
and and show him that you see him and
you hear him i wonder yousaf what is
your next step i know that you're based
in the georgia area but not so long ago
there were some reports that you were
thinking of maybe running for public
office maybe in new york
yes so my next steps i'm still doing the
great work that i've continued to do
working with the innocence project and
the marshall project you know work with
my mother and her organization justice
for the wrongfully incarcerated we're
trying to
make sure that we give people a fighting
chance and ultimately it's about not
giving up the hope and the dream that is
inside of you that you were born with
right you know looking at politics from
that perspective
at this particular point i thought that
it might be
um not advantageous for me to run in
this moment but i'm not giving up my
future possibility of putting my hat in
the ring because i know that those
individuals that should be at the table
should be the ones who are closest to
the problem and i'm of course one of
those who's been on both sides of the
fence working on the outside now but
once was working on the inside on myself
and on others that sought my help and
assistance trying to get through this
individual this this awful experience
um
so i think collectively as we look at
what the future may hold
i'm i'm excited as to what that looks
like i'm excited to participate
on a very very high level
um it's almost prophetic
where would you do that would you do
that in georgia or would you do that in
your home state of new york
i'm still considering the options of
course i live in georgia and i'm a
globetrotter at this particular point in
my life
um it's easy for me to go here and there
and anywhere
but i'm still i'm still considering my
options
okay yusuf when you figure them out
please let us know yousef salam thank
you so much for joining us today